muy buenas noches valentina muchas
gracias por la gente la invitación sin
duda lo que hemos venido viendo el ahora
en estas elecciones pues para los
jóvenes es un déjà vú es decir una
historia que se repite a lo que se vio
hace cinco años estamos viendo
nuevamente estos dos rivales políticos
que se enfrentan a esta segunda vuelta a
valentina donde en esta primera vuelta
vimos un abstencionismo de casi el 30
por ciento y lo que se teme en este
próximo domingo es que nuevamente el
abstencionismo avance y que este voto
que está ya que de hecho se pulverizó al
haber tenido 12 candidatos en la primera
vuelta pues ahora se está apostando al
voto de los jóvenes al voto a los
indecisos pero lo más importante es
poder combatir el abstencionismo
porque lo importante es fortalecer la
democracia del interior de francia y más
allá de las expectativas que ha dicho de
economía pero también ipsos trans pues
es que le está apostando entre un 53 y
un 57
donde el triunfo de manuel manco por lo
tanto estaríamos viéndolo en un nuevo
mandato en el elíseo pero nada fácil
valentina una francia con muchas aristas
muchos desafíos no sólo el interior de
la agenda doméstica sino también en
cuanto a las directrices que tendrá que
tomar el rumbo y la ley y el liderazgo
al interior de la unión europea del otan
del g7 y sin olvidar que es miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad de
la hoja bueno y que tan representativo
puede ser el programa de manuel ma com
para la izquierda francesa volviendo un
poco a los seguidores de melón son hay
algunos puntos que coinciden
que cásate tu pregunta
valentina porque hemos visto que estas
diversidad de plataformas por un lado
estamos viendo un ultraderechista que es
ma jin de pe pero por el otro lado
totalmente opuesto al 'groupe bel' en
shock que es ultraizquierdista a favor
de los programas sociales y entonces en
el centro se ubica en una nueva co con
una continuidad una promesa de políticas
públicas sanas
y entonces de acuerdo a lo que este
tercer candidato obtuvo de un 21 por
ciento el resultado electoral lo que le
está invitando a su base electoral es
que no voten por ella porque es
totalmente alejada de su plataforma
política no dice que voten por el pp
manuel majo pero si dicen no voten por
ella entonces está 21 por ciento que
ganó ahora lo importante es ver cómo es
que lograrán atrapar lo enmarcó
recordemos que la primera vuelta panamá
con logró cautivar el voto
y el voto de una edad de votantes
adultas y adultos mayores sin embargo me
leyó atrajo el voto de la juventud estos
jóvenes digamos de 34 años para abajo
que ahora en agile penn les está
hablando y les está prometiendo que no
les va a cobrar el impuesto sobre la
renta está prometiendo bajar el impuesto
del 20 al 5.5 por ciento en combustibles
en productos básicos de la canasta
básica y donde ahora vemos que por eso
es que me leyó está invitando que no
voten por ella porque lo más cercano o
recibirlo así pues vendría haciendo esta
propuesta de centro de emanuel marco
pero sin duda el domingo será lo que en
realidad estará votando la decisión del
ciudadano francés así de señora
contreras a usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo con nosotros
en france 24
a contra de valentina muchas gracias a
ti y esperamos lo mejor por la sociedad
y el país de francia pues esta decisión
tan importante al interior de dicha
nación muchas gracias y muy buenas
noches